[Musique]
bientôt midi sur LCI soyez les bienvenus
si vous nous rejoignez c'était un peu
son moment et il a été un petit peu
éclipsé légitimement par le Président de
la République Marc féno inauguré hier le
salon de l'agriculture aux portes de
Paris séance de rattrapage dans quelques
minutes pour le ministre de
l'Agriculture car il est l'invité du
Grand Jury RTL le Figaro Arnold Chabaud
beaucoup de séquences intéressantes
intéressantes hier on l'a dit au salon
de l'agriculture même s'il ne faut pas
faire oublier que en plus des retraites
il y a toujours cette profession
l'agriculteurs a rassuré aujourd'hui
voyez beaucoup de points qui sont
importants pour effectivement les
agriculteurs faut jamais oublier qu'il y
a un tiers des agriculteurs qui ont pris
leur retraite dans 10 ans ça veut dire
qu'il y a des problèmes évidemment pour
leur succession pour notamment dans
l'élevage c'est une vraie difficulté
deuxièmement les agriculteurs ils ont un
problème de prix hier le président de la
République a dit qu'effectivement
notamment la grande distribution devait
faire des efforts on sait qu'il y a eu
des lois votées
les gains et un pouvoir d'achat et des
ventes de niveau des prix des
agriculteurs mais néanmoins c'est
toujours compliqué et puis évidemment il
y a le problème de la sécheresse du
climat avec un plan de se briété annoncé
par le président et le ministre en
charge de la transition et que logique
mais les choses clairement sur la table
aujourd'hui en disant que et bien l'eau
les ressources en eau vont diminuer de
10 à 40% dans les années qui viennent et
ce plan de d'économie d'eau va être
présenté sans doute dans les jours qui
viennent par le gouvernement donc ça
fait beaucoup de gros sujets à partager
au sein du gouvernement mais notamment
qui doivent être défendus par le
ministre de l'Agriculture qui parlera
aussi des échanges sans doute un peu
houeux hier entre le Président de la
République et des activistes
écologistes de dernière rénovation qui
ont été on sait un tout petit peu
violent et en tout cas je vais pas dire
qu'il y a des échanges parce qu'en fait
il y a pas eu d'échanges puisqu'ils
accusé de parler au président de la
République un ministre qui va aussi
passer sur le grill quand même pendant
une heure et qui va certainement aussi
répondre aux questions sur le système
des retraites parce qu'elle a aussi il
devra défendre la réforme de son
gouvernement oui alors même s'il y a pas
eu beaucoup d'interpellations du
Président on peut quand même remarquer
parce que c'est le débat qui va
commencer demain
la réponse est maintenant c'est le grand
jury qui commence
[Musique]
le Grand Jury RTL le Figaro LCI Marie
mollet bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce
grand jury RTL LCI Le Figaro bonjour
Marc feno bonjour merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous vous êtes ministre de
l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire le salon de l'agriculture
vient de s'ouvrir dans un climat de
grandes incertitudes 40% des
agriculteurs partiront à la retraite
d'ici 10 ans 10 000 fermes disparaissent
chaque année les importations explosent
alors l'agriculture française est-elle
en danger de mort comment sauver notre
souveraineté alimentaire sans sacrifié
nos engagements environnementaux et
après la sécheresse record cet hiver
faut-il se préparer à une guerre de
l'eau entre agriculteurs et particuliers
nous allons en parler bienvenue Marc
feno ce grand jury est en direct vous
pouvez vous pouvez poser toutes vos
questions sur tous les réseaux sociaux
avec le hashtag le Grand Jury Marie
pierradad bonjour bonjour de la
rédaction de RTL Marie-Pierre scrute vos
questions vos réactions et nous alertes
avec ce signal
et pour vous interroger à nos côtés Jim
Jarreau bonjour Jim et Damien Fleurot de
TF1 LCI bonjour Damien Damien qui vous
pose la première question de ce grand
jury
vous avez accompagné le président de la
République hier au salon de
l'agriculture une visite marathon une
visite avec un accueil on va dire mitigé
en tous les cas il a parfois été chahuté
Emmanuel Macron interpellé notamment par
un militant écologiste du collectif
dernière rénovation échange musclé
écouter
gentiment
monsieur fait tous les rapports
scientifiques vous le disent pourquoi
vous ne les écoutez pas il y aura rien
qui nous arrêtera j'ai fini ce que
j'avais à dire vous n'êtes pas entendu
monsieur vous êtes la démonstration vous
êtes déjà entendu la démonstration d'une
forme de violence civile non il y a pas
de violence
voilà vous êtes la démonstration d'une
forme de violence civique vous n'êtes
pas respectueux a dit le président de la
République le dialogue et rompu marque
PHENO avec ses militants écologistes le
dialogue est rompu avec ceux qui veulent
leur la vérité
c'est militants portaient des t-shirts
en disant à quoi tu sers alors je sais
pas qui se posait la question mais elle
se pose à tout le monde à quoi tu sers
et à quoi ça sert au fond d'avoir des
actes qui sont simplement des actes de
dénonciation de constatation et on a
besoin plutôt de gens qui s'engagent qui
ont envie de travailler sur les sujets
agricoles comme sur bien d'autres sujets
et de dénonciation ou des lanceurs
d'alerte oui non il y a un moment lancé
des alertes dénoncé être spectateur est
une chose est acteur c'est mieux je
pense qu'on a besoin de particulier chez
les jeunes il y en a beaucoup c'est
plutôt cela auquel il faut s'adresser
aussi qui s'engage pour essayer de
rendre un peu les choses meilleures au
fur et à mesure moi je crois beaucoup à
ce qu'on appelait la fable du Colibri
chacun doit faire sa part nous devons
faire notre part elle est importante
parce que nous gouvernants nous sommes
en situation de responsabilité il y a
des parlementaires et des acteurs
économiques qui essaient de faire
évoluer les choses tout le monde sait
que ce sont des transitions et venir
dire que nous ne sommes pas sur ce
chemin de la transition c'est une erreur
la vérité c'est que nous tenons compte y
compris des rapports divers et variés
qui ne manquent pas de nous alerter
lorsque militants dit au président de la
République des vies sont en jeu est-ce
que vous dites aujourd'hui qu'il exagère
que c'est une vision
apocalyptique des enjeux non mais la
question climatique en particulier parce
que c'est surtout sur celle-là qu'il a
l'air elle a l'air évidemment sur des
dérèglements climatiques qui peuvent
produire ici et la sécheresse là des
inondations ça n'est pas complètement
nouveau d'ailleurs mais l'accélération
du phénomène il porte des risques on en
reparlera sans doute tout à l'heure en
terme de souveraineté alimentaire il
porte des risques en termes de phénomène
cataclysmique d'un point de vue
météorologique qui peuvent poser des
questions en termes de vie mais c'est
une responsabilité collective que nous
avons mais en même temps on peut pas
simplement être je le répète dans la
dénonciation et dans la constatation il
faut qu'on essaie de se saisir des
choses c'est pas parce qu'il y a des
dangers qu'il y a des difficultés devant
nous
qu'il faut simplement rester figé dire
je constate qu'il y a des dangers qu'on
va tous mourir ça peut pas être un
slogan qu'on va tous mourir le slogan
c'est qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour éviter
les risques qu'on a devant nous devant
en particulier ces risques face aux
dérèglements une question web avec
Marie-pierre Adèle oui il y a une phrase
d'Emmanuel Macron qui a particulièrement
dérangé certains internautes il a
interpellé ce militants et il lui a dit
je suis élu par le peuple français vous
vous êtes élu par qui ça ressemble à
beaucoup de mépris selon Adeline et
d'autres internautes est-ce que c'était
vraiment nécessaire comme aucun mépris à
dire et à rappeler ce qu'est l'ordre de
la légitimité nous sommes en démocratie
en démocratie
les décisions procèdent d'un vote
souverain des citoyens et donc il y a
des parlementaires il y a des sénateurs
et des députés il y a des corps
intermédiaires qui sont eux-mêmes élus
le président n'a pas dit qu'il ne
l'écoutait pas le ce jeune disait vous
n'avez pas la légitimité bah si la
légitimité l'onction de la suite du
suffrage universel du démocratique et
dès lors qu'il a ça il a une légitimité
et ça n'est pas la même chose que
d'avoir une expression individuelle que
le président écoutait d'ailleurs je
rappelle que ce jeune a essayé à
plusieurs reprises de dire je ne veux
pas discuter avec vous enfin on peut pas
être dans un débat démocratique remettre
en question le vote démocratique quand
bien même on ne soit pas d'accord avec
personne ne lui demande d'être d'accord
avec l'issue du vote et par ailleurs
refuser le débat à titre individuel
enfin il y a quelque chose qui qui
dysfonctionne quand on se comporte ainsi
il y a un autre message aussi sur
Twitter qui a été énormément repris
c'est celui de Sandrine Rousseau elle
dit c'est un problème il y a un problème
de déni d'urgence climatique de la part
d'Emmanuel Macron lui répondez non il y
a aucun problème madame Rousseau écoute
lumière de tweets pour essayer de faire
parler mais ce n'est pas le sujet
personne ne dit qu'il n'y a pas
d'urgence simplement la transition
industrielle agricole et autres elle
nécessite des transitions sinon vous
faites le système et donc vous ne vous
n'êtes pas au rendez-vous de la
transition donc personne n'a dit qu'il
n'y avait pas d'urgence nous sommes le
pays regardons ce qui se passe à
l'extérieur de nos frontières à
l'extérieur des frontières européennes
nous sommes la région et le pays qui
fait le plus d'efforts en termes de
réduction des gaz à effet de serre donc
on a un combat mené au niveau mondial
pour faire en sorte que les autres sans
saisissent mais ne commençons pas à dire
que nous ne faisons rien mais il y a une
urgence c'est vrai qu'on est obligé de
courir un peu derrière ce dérèglement
qui s'accélère mais on peut courir au
rythme qui est acceptable qui est
supportable par les systèmes par les
systèmes tel qui se sont organisés
depuis des dizaines d'années pendant la
visite du président de la République un
jeune homme a été molesté de façon assez
violente par les services d'or du
président de la République vous avez vu
la vidéo j'ai vu la vidéo est-ce que
vous estimez qu'il y a une erreur là du
service d'hommes je vais vous dire j'ai
tendance d'ailleurs le président de la
République a dû lui-même dans la dans la
foulée
faut toujours se méfier de la vidéo qui
soit sorti du contexte donc je n'ai pas
d'avis négatif ou positif le président
de la République a dit que lui-même que
toute forme de violence pour lui était à
essayer d'écarter et devait être écartés
après faut savoir dans quelles
conditions de quel ordre de menace moi
je vous rendre hommage aussi à des gens
qui dans des conditions il y a beaucoup
de foule beaucoup de gens sont venus
aussi vers le président de la République
qui pour faire des photos qui pour
donner un dossier individuel qui pourra
dire et faire part de tenez bon tenez
bon tenez bon d'autre pour dire qu'ils
étaient pas d'accord sur les sujets de
retraite service d'ordre dans ces
conditions-là c'est très compliqué de
déterminer le degré de risque c'est pas
moi de juger là sur une vidéo de ce qui
s'est passé j'imagine que ça sera
regardé avec attention parce que si on
peut s'éviter ce genre de d'épisode
évidemment mais moi j'étais toute la
journée avec le président de la
République le service d'ordre il était à
la pression de foule qui voulait lui
parler ou qui voulait l'interpeller sur
tel ou tel sujet ça peut arriver ça peut
être regrettable si c'est le cas
nous venons de traverser une sécheresse
hivernale historique 32 jours sans pluie
les nappes phréatiques ont deux mois de
retard de remplissage une réunion doit
se tenir demain matin avec Christophe
Béchu votre collègue ministre de la
transition écologique avec les préfets
pour déterminer territoire par
territoire si des restrictions d'eau
doivent être prises dès de mois de mars
est-ce que c'est restrictions qui
existent déjà dans certains départements
notamment les Pyrénées-Orientales
peuvent être étendues demain matin on
verra si en fonction de la situation et
c'est tout l'objet de ces réunions alors
c'est bien ce sont des réunions qui se
déroulent théoriquement plutôt au mois
d'avril mai ou juin quand la saison
d'été s'ouvre là on est sur un phénomène
alors cet historique mais ce n'est pas
ce n'est pas unique il est déjà arrivé
qu'au mois de février nous soyons dans
cette situation de faible plus géométrie
la difficulté c'est qu'on arrive sur une
faible plus après une année qui a été
elle-même très sèche et donc on est sur
une situation de nappe et de difficulté
qui est très grande donc le donc les
restrictions vont s'étendre vous dites
on verra en fonction de la situation
mais il est probable que demain sur un
certain nombre de départements alors
c'est des restrictions d'anticipation
quel type de départ vous avez un certain
nombre de départements ont été cités les
Pyrénées-Orientales il y en a un aussi
on valait du Rhône je crois que c'est
dans l'Isère qu'il y a des sujets de
restriction qui sont en train d'être
posés l'idée c'est de d'anticiper
suffisamment tôt dans l'hypothèse où
nous n'aurions pas de pluie ce que nous
savons ni vous ni moi
dans l'hypothèse où nous ne serions pas
suffisamment de plis d'essayer de
préserver autant que faire ce peu la
ressource en eau qui est une ressource
qui est précieuse qui est précieuse pour
nous être humain qui est précieuse pour
nous être humain dans le processus de
fabrication de produits agricoles et
donc c'est plutôt cette anticipation
qu'on essaie de faire mais la vérité si
il pleut comme il pleut d'habitude
régulièrement au printemps nous n'aurons
pas de difficulté puisqu'on nous
n'aurons pas besoin de prélever dans les
nappes ou dans les cours d'eau la
difficulté c'est si nous continuions à
avoir une météorologie comme celle-là
donc c'est ça qu'il faut anticiper au
cas où et je pense que l'anticipation
c'est la meilleure chose qu'on peut
faire il y a des restrictions qui sont
déjà prises vous l'avez dit dans
certains départements comme le
remplissage des piscines ou l'arrosage
est-ce que d'autres restrictions peuvent
être prises concrètement pour limiter la
consommation
les priorités c'est vrai que le
remplissage d'une piscine le nettoyage
de sa voiture c'est quand même sans
doute moins prioritaire que d'autres
usages parlent même pas de l'eau potable
pour boire tout simplement mais c'est
moins priorit que les usages agricoles
au fur et à mesure c'est ce qu'on a fait
l'an dernier j'aurais comme saluer le
travail compris en responsabilité qui a
été qui a été fait avec les agriculteurs
et avec les autres usagers pour dire on
graduent en fonction de la menace et du
risque de pénurie des usages du plus
accessoires sans jeter la pierre à
personne ou plus essentielle se nourrir
et pouvoir boire tout simplement
Emmanuel Macron a annoncé hier un plan
de sobriété sur l'eau sur le même modèle
que plante sobriété énergétique alors de
façon très très concrète qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire est-ce que ça veut dire que
vous allez dire aux Français il faut
prendre une douche par jour maximum en
effet arrêter de laver sa voiture devant
chez soi de façon très très concrète ça
veut dire quoi un plan de sobriété de
faire ce qu'on a fait sur la sobriété
énergétique c'est-à-dire sans donner de
leçon
sans infantiliser de dire voilà les
gestes que chacun peut faire au
quotidien mais par exemple
on peut plutôt une douche qu'un bain on
lave pas sa voiture ou on arrose son
potager quand on en a ou ses fleurs à
une période qui est moins ensoleillée au
moins chaude parce que c'est dans cette
période là que c'est plus c'est le plus
efficace sans doute voilà c'est toute
une série de mesures qu'on peut prendre
quotidiennement pour essayer
d'économiser et tout ça fait un fait
quand même une somme de choses mais ce
qu'il faut aller vers des objectifs
chiffrés par créneaux à moyen terme ou à
long terme on va pas se dire on va pas
fixer des objectifs chiffrés à des
Français d'abord parce qu'on n'a pas
enfin là on tomberait dans quand même
dans un système un peu cavalien pour pas
dire que le cousin c'est à dire qu'on
n'est pas là non plus pour dire vous
avez le droit à tendre des litres d'eau
par personne mais aujourd'hui par
exemple les Français consomment en
moyenne 147 litres d'eau par jour est-ce
que vous dites bah il faut abaisser ce
chiffre il faut arriver là on peut
essayer de se donner des objectifs
plutôt d'attitude de gestes des cogestes
j'allais dire ou de au G qui permettrait
de se poser la question pour l'objectif
de réduire est un objectif important je
vous donne les affaires d'eau c'est je
vous donne trois chiffres 500
33 3 500 c'est 500 milliards de mètres
cubes c'est ce qui tombe comme au chaque
année sur le sol français
33 c'est ce qui est prélevé vous voyez
déjà on est 533 et dans les 33 il y en a
trois qui sont prélevés par
l'agriculture donc voyez bien qu'on a
des usages qui sont de nature différente
et que ce qu'a dit le président de la
République hier ça nécessite que chacun
fasse ça par des forces est valable pour
les Français c'est valable pour les
industries agroalimentaires par exemple
puisqu'on va on a un décret au Conseil
d'État qui est publié qui va permettre
de réutiliser on va y venir les eaux
utilisés c'est valable pour les
agriculteurs c'est valable pour tout le
monde essayez à chaque fois de se poser
la question faut qu'on comprenne comme
une denrée rare au fond une question
même Marie peradol oui justement par
rapport à toutes ces gestes du quotidien
que vous avez cité le fait de ne pas
arroser ses plantes quand il fait trop
chaud le fait de prendre une douche
plutôt qu'un bain tout ça ça fait déjà
plusieurs années que les Français le
font ils ont déjà été sensibilisés à ces
messages là qu'est-ce qu'il y a de
nouveau en fait c'est d'essayer de se
mettre collectivement en route en marche
vous pourriez faire exactement le même
le même la même récrimination sur les
économies d'énergie
on disait j'entendais à l'époque au mois
de septembre octobre les Français l'ont
déjà fait on fait longtemps qu'on dit
qu'il faut économiser d'énergie qu'il
faut éteindre la lumière en sortant
d'une pièce que enfin et que c'est
plutôt 19 degrés mais la vérité c'est
qu'on a quand même réussi par ces gestes
du quotidien à passer le cap de l'hiver
et donc il y a sans doute encore des
marges et donc la pédagogie faut jamais
se lasser d'essayer de discuter ensemble
déjà ce qu'on peut faire les uns et les
autres pour essayer d'économiser est-ce
qu'on l'éteint vous vous dites que une
partie des récoltes de 2023 sont
compromises ou
ou que en tout cas la sécheresse peut
impacter le prix et peut peser sur les
cours des récoltes non alors là vous me
posez une question qui appelle pardon
juste plusieurs réponses la question des
prix ça n'est pas une question que des
récoltes en France c'est une question de
récolte dans le monde et c'est une
question aussi de quelle est la
situation géopolitique donc vous ne
répondez non deux le 25 ou le 26 février
je ne peux pas vous dire
je n'aurais d'ailleurs pas pu vous
répondre quoi que ce soit le 25 février
2022 sur le sujet et d'ailleurs si vous
m'aviez interrogé le 22 février 2022 je
vous aurais dit que les prix aller être
faible et que globalement l'année
s’annonçait plutôt bonne et il n'est pas
pareil de dire si nous avons un
printemps qui est plutôt sec c'est
plutôt sur ce qu'on récolte juste en
entrée d'été et si on a un été plutôt
humide c'est plutôt favorable à d'autres
formes donc à date simplement on a
besoin d'être très vigilant et regarder
quels sont les risques que nous avons de
vendre
oui l'une des pistes sur lesquelles vous
souhaitez avancer vous en avez dit un
mot c'est le recyclage des eaux usées
des villes dans l'agriculture la France
est en retard sur ce sujet par rapport à
d'autres pays en Europe en Espagne ou en
Italie vous avez annoncé que la
législation allait bouger en décrire au
Conseil d'État ce sera opérationnel
quand dès cet été l'idée c'est d'être
opérationnel de cet été parce que c'est
un décan Conseil d'État donc le Conseil
d'État en validera le cadre juridique et
est-ce qu'on est déjà équipé pour
traiter ces os mais et ses oreilles le
sujet ce n'était pas quelles étaient
traités ou pas traités elles étaient
traitées le sujet c'était une fois
traité ce qu'on peut les réutiliser je
vais vous donner un exemple vous vous
êtes dans la filière pomme de terre vous
rincez vos pommes de terre
ou les envoyer dans une station de
traitement sur le site de l'usine quand
même la logique voudrait qu'on puisse
les réutiliser dans le cycle pour éviter
ce qu'on fait d'ailleurs dans la plupart
des cas c'est qu'on les renvoie au
milieu donc si on les renvoie au milieu
c'est qu'on doit considérer que les
critères de salubrité sont respectées
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui se passe sur
toutes les stations d'épurations là on
est sur une station d'épuration
industrielle quand même la logique c'est
qu'il puisse le réutiliser parce que ça
permet d'éviter de regrouper dans la
nappe ce qu'on peut avoir en économie
circulaire donc c'est tout ça qu'il faut
regarder nous avions alors c'est tout le
mal français on en parlera peut-être sur
d'autres sujets c'est on est toujours
jamais en retard d'une interdiction
d'une contrainte et jamais en avance
d'une solution c'est qu'une question
réglementaire on est certainement il
suffit d'appuyer sur le bouton
j'ai la prudence pour avoir une longue
expérience y compris des lieux locales
de dire que s'il suffit pas d'appuyer
sur le bouton mais c'est un sujet
c'était un sujet réglementaire
d'ailleurs la preuve en Allemagne c'est
plus de 10% en Italie c'est plus de 15
ou 16 % nous sommes dans le même espace
européen j'ai pas le sentiment qu'il y
ait des problèmes de salubrité ou de ou
dans ces deux pays votre objectif pour
la France vous dites il faut qu'on
puisse arriver 10 15% il faut qu'on
arrive à ces feuilles là dans les dans
les cinq ou dix années oui absolument
parce que alors c'est toujours long
parce que évidemment quand vous aviez
des entreprises qui avaient fait le
choix d'essayer de recycler et à qui on
disait non vous pouvez pas le mettre
dans votre cycle de production bah ils
avaient un système qui s'était organisé
différemment donc on a besoin aussi les
industriels ont besoin qu'on leur envoie
des messages et donc on a besoin de
travailler sur ça de même que voilà on a
besoin de travailler sur des sujets qui
permettent aux industriels de se
préparer et de faire là aussi de la
planification pour la transition Kim
Jarra c'est un autre sujet qui est
important c'est celui des fuites d'eau
20% de l'eau potable et perdue à cause
des fuites d'eau à Caen un grand plan
pour bien rénover les canalisations
vétus ça coûte extrêmement cher mais
peut-être que c'est nécessaire mais
c'est nécessaire ce n'est pas très
nouveau que c'est nécessaire
dès qu'on dit j'essaye de dire que vous
avez vous voyez bien des distorsions
entre une commune vous avez des prix de
l'eau qui sont parfois à quatre ou cinq
euros au Hasni d'autres qui sont à 1 €
bah vous pouvez imaginer quand même que
cette différence elle est descendu à un
sous-investissement c'est valable aussi
pour les lycées c'est valable pour les
écoles c'est pas pour moi mais il y a
besoin d'investissement lourd on a été
plutôt côté y compris de des
collectivités y compris je le dis dans
le plan de relance mais on a besoin de
travailler parce que c'est vrai que
cette cette perte d'eau est une perte
importante elle est d'ailleurs et c'est
là qu'on a une difficulté plus
importante en milieu rurale parce que
d'abord on a plus de conduite
mécaniquement et de il y a moins de
moyens donc on a besoin de mieux
structurer ça est-ce que le gouvernement
est prêt à mettre de l'argent sur la
table pour accompagner la filière la
filière de l'eau qui chiffre à 17
milliards d'euros le budget nécessaire
pour anticiper un changement climatique
combien le gouvernement va mettre sur ma
vie le fait déjà au travers des
politiques publiques je dis il l'a fait
au travers de France relance il le fait
chaque année au travers de la dotation
d'équipement des territoires ruraux il
le fait au travers de ce qui ce qui est
financé aussi par les agences de l'eau
il y a quand même des mécanismes qui
existent aujourd'hui de financement il
faut que chacun prenne sa part après
j'imagine quand on va travailler avec
Christophe mechut sur ces questions là
alors c'est plutôt dans son périmètre
parce que c'est le périmètre des
collectivités qu'on regardera s'il y a
des moyens supplémentaires sans doute au
travers des agences de l'eau qui ont été
souvent des des établissements qui ont
permis de financer à ces puissants parce
que le principe qu'on la pose en France
qui est un bon principe c'est que l'eau
paye l'eau et que donc c'est comme ça
que le système doit s'équilibrer alors
vous défendez marcéno le déploiement des
retenu d'eau c'est bassines méga
bassines qui permettent aux agriculteurs
de capter l'eau des nappes phréatiques
en hiver pour les stocker et pouvoir
ensuite irriguer en été la question qui
se pose en ce moment c'est la suivante
quand les nappes phréatiques sont vides
en hiver comme c'est le cas dans
certaines régions à quoi ça sert ces
retenues d'eau parce qu'il y a plus
d'eau dans les nappes phréatiques
il va tomber de l'eau en France
en moyenne c'est 600 mm donc ça va
tomber un moment qui a des années où ça
ne tombe pas en hiver comme disait
l'autre c'est c'est un cas mais c'est
pas la majorité de l'espèce donc la
règle générale c'est de l'eau entre le
15 et que les nappes se remplissent
entre le 1er novembre et le 1er mars ou
le 1er avril bon nous sommes dans une
année atypique on imagine bien que dans
des années comme celle-là quand il y a
des retenues dossiers peuvent pas se
remplir et bien ils peuvent pas se
remplir donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut à
la fois qu'on est des retenues d'eau les
années on aura de l'eau et la majorité
des cas c'est dans cette période-là
qu'on pourra remplir ça n'empêche pas ce
qu'a dit d'ailleurs hier le président de
la République qu'on travaille aussi à
des systèmes agricoles qui soient plus
résilients on va parce qu'il y a des
années où ça sera très atypique où ça
sera très difficile de remplir et là on
aura des difficultés donc faut aussi
préparer notre modèle agricole à cela
anticipe justement des nappes
phréatiques qui sont de plus en plus
vite donc on a on s'interroge est-ce que
ça sert à quelque chose d'investir des
millions d'euros dans des ouvrages de
retenue d'eau si un moment donné les
nappes phréatiques sont vides et qu'on
peut plus le système de prévision dit
pas tout à fait ça dépend des régions et
ça dépend de la nature des notes donc
essayons déjà d'essayer de faire de la
différenciation ça nécessite d'ailleurs
que nous ayons des approches
territoriales et pas des applocks se
faisant empiriques il y a des régions
sans doute où les nappes sont plus
remplies parce qu'il va tomber plus
d'eau bon c'est ça le dérèglement je
rappelle que c'est un système
anthropique est donc la quantité d'Oka
qui traîne sur la terre est la même donc
il y a des régions chez nous y compris
chez nous il y aura plus d'eau et des
régions il y aura moins d'eau donc on a
besoin de penser des systèmes comme cela
commençons par dire à chaque fois qu'on
essaie de trouver des systèmes où on est
économie d'eau comme on l'a dit deuxième
élément fait évoluer les pratiques
agricoles dans des secteurs on sait que
la tension de l'eau va faire que les uns
seulement comme on dit vont changer et
puis dans certains endroits on a besoin
d'eau la surface irriguée en France vous
savez combien c'est 7%
oui ce que je veux dire donc on parle
d'un sujet qui est sur l'essentiel des
surfaces de France ne sont pas irriguées
il y a des endroits il y aura besoin
sans doute irriguer parce que le climat
va changer mais essayons de le faire on
pondération parce que la vérité
l'histoire les romans les films même
sont peuplés d'histoire qui posent des
problèmes d'accès à l'eau l'histoire de
l'humanité c'est le défi de l'accès à
l'eau c'est pas nouveau hein sauf que
nous étions dans un pays tempéré et nous
n'avions pas l'habitude de cela mais
donc la gestion de l'eau c'est devant
nous effectivement une question que le
hashtag le Grand Jury oui vous savez que
ce sujet des méga bassines à chaque fois
ces projets sont fortement contestés
localement il a des manifestations voire
même des occupations de sites marine
tonded la patronne des écologistes a
recommencé à lancer la mobilisation
contre ces gavassines sur Twitter parce
qu'il y aura une mobilisation dans un
mois le 25 mars est-ce que vous redoutez
des affrontements
ne serait-ce que poser cette question ça
pose un problème
on peut ne pas être d'accord avec un
projet mais dès lors que la violence
vient s'immiscer et que par la violence
qui entendent par la violence remettent
en cause le droit au fond parce que dans
ces projets là le droit est passé les
recours ont été purgés les analyses
scientifiques ont été faites et donc
vous avez des gens qui malgré ça
considèrent que désormais ayant épuisé
les voies démocratiques ils prennent les
autres voies qui sont les voix de la
force des gens
vous avez peur de la violence je réponds
à cette question là deuxième élément
je vous donne là aussi c'est très simple
l'affaire de sainte Soline c'est 21
millions de mètres cubes qui étaient
prélevés en été il est prévu dans le
projet de Sainte-Soline que par ses
réserves qu'on constitue l'hiver on ne
prélève plus que 13 millions en tout que
dans ces 13 millions il y en est la
moitié qui soit prélevé l'été le reste
par les constitution d'une réserve
l'hiver si ça c'est pas vertueux
qu'est-ce que propose madame Tondelier
elle propose de faire de l'agriculture
sans eau elle sait le que 95% d'une
tomate c'est de l'eau elle sait que le
blé a besoin de plus d'eau que le maïs
elle sait que les animaux ont besoin
d'eau elle sait que 2 pour faire de
l'herbe il faut de l'eau et donc si on
commence à juste poser des yakafocons et
qu'on ne me donne que la le rejet des
solutions qu'on essaie de porter y
compris dans ce qu'elles ont de vertueux
il y a de quoi porter de la désespérance
et même mon énervement ce qui est assez
rare sur ces sujets là parce que je
comprends que les agriculteurs en est un
peu marre qu'on leur explique que faites
des efforts et que même avec ces efforts
là ça suffit pas elle propose quoi elle
propose qu'on arrose plus les propos ce
qui est plus d'eau elle propose un
modèle agricole sans eau ça n'existe pas
il va falloir que on reprenne les cycles
de la vie végétale et de de ce que
l'apprentissage de la science sans eau
il n'y a pas d'agriculture voilà vous
allez faire 5000 km plus au sud et vous
allez voir ce que c'est qu'un pays où on
peut pas avoir de l'eau nous on a de
l'eau donc il faut pouvoir la mobiliser
au moment où on en a besoin et c'est pas
valable c'est valable pour toutes les
productions mais plus touchées cette
année c'est les maraîchers
marine trondelier non mais à la fin non
mais à la fin quand vous voyez le bout
du bout du processus je vous décris
sainte solide si ça n'est pas vertueux
qu'est-ce qui est vertueux c'est pas
d'eau non les écologistes proposent Marc
fenault notamment d'adapter des formes
de culture de changer mais c'est ce
qu'ils ont fait à Sainte Soline c'est
une réduction aussi d'un certain nombre
de surfaces par exemple de maïs qui sont
trop pénalisés compte tenu des sols donc
c'est ça qui va pas dans cette affaire
c'est qu'ils le font aussi et donc
personne n'entendre ça c'est une espèce
d'impasse parce qu'on est dans le Yaka
fauconismes le plus absolu le plus
abouti et le plus inutile moi j'ai
besoin qu'on produise j'ai besoin qu'on
assume la souveraineté j'ai besoin qu'on
fasse des économies d'eau j'ai besoin
que les modèles agricoles changent j'ai
pas besoin qu'on ait des gens qui soient
là commenter et qui n'est pas de
solution à proposer alors Marcelo
Christophe BECHU votre collègue
ministère transition écologique
travaille sur un scénario plus 4 degrés
en France alors à quoi est-ce que vous
avez commencé à penser à quoi ça
ressemble l'agriculture avec plus 4
degrés est-ce que ça veut dire qu'il y a
des oliviers au-dessus de la Loire qui a
du vent en Bretagne est-ce que vous
pouvez nous donner à voir à quoi
pourrait ressembler la France nos
paysages nos assiettes alors non alors
c'est d'ailleurs le train qui lance donc
je peux pas vous dire puisque le travail
que veut lancer Christophe bechus c'est
de regarder en prospective ce que donne
4 parce que les prospectives ont été
plutôt entre entre 1 et 2 donc c'est le
travail qu'on a devant nous mais là où
vous dites quelque chose qui est très
juste c'est que profondément
l'agriculture c'est des savoir-faire
donne et de femmes c'est un sol et c'est
un climat et donc quand l'image change
quelque chose change et je vois bien les
efforts qui sont faits
par les arboriculteurs qui sont faits
par les viticulteurs pour adapter les
variétés
avec l'aide des instituts de recherche
qui soit adaptés l'INRA et en
particulier les autres qui sont faits
pour pour avoir des essences qui sont
plus adaptables oui il y a des projets
aujourd'hui de gens qui font des
amandiers au sud de la France n'aurait
pas pensé que nous oui il y a des
territoires on va pouvoir faire cultiver
du blé avec plus 4 degrés en France oui
on peut cultiver du bled jusqu'à deux
grands France d'ailleurs historiquement
le blé était plutôt
plus au sud quand vous regardez
l'histoire du blé il vient plutôt
des terres en particulier le blé dur
donc on peut cultiver du blé pourquoi
quel est l'avantage du blé c'est que il
a besoin de plus donc le maïs mais qu'il
est dans il arrive généralement sauf
cette année mais on verra comment se
déroule le printemps dans une période où
il y a encore de l'eau en réserve dans
les sols donc le blé on peut en faire
mais si nous n'avions pas fait de la
recherche variétale y compris sur le
maïs le maïs on a réduit 30 de 20 à 30%
la le besoin d'eau par la sélection
variétale et c'est ce qu'on fera est-ce
que ce qu'on veut faire aussi sur le blé
ça c'est une voix aussi pour moi avoir
de stress hydrique et de stress
thermique sélection
variable et également modification
génétique est-ce que vous y êtes
favorable pour favoriser des espèces qui
seraient plus résistantes à la
sécheresse la Commission européenne y
est favorable quel est votre position
sur cette favorable parce qu'on peut pas
les mêmes vous vous disent refuse aussi
les nouvelles technologies qu'est-ce que
c'est ce qui est proposé c'est le nouvel
technique génomique qui ne sont pas des
OGM pourquoi on vient quelle est la même
relance on vient greffer un gène d'une
variété de blé sur une variété de blé
donc c'est on est bien sur la même donc
il y a pas de risque mais comme ceux qui
avaient question génétique oui très bien
mais vous savez que nous sommes tous
autour de cette table produit d'une
modification génétique et même de
plusieurs modifications génétiques
pendant des centaines de millions
d'années nous ne sommes que
modifications génétique nous tous dans
cette salle et là à se parler donc la
modification génétique ça arrive c'est
d'ailleurs souvent des accidents et le
fruit du hasard là l'idée encore sur ces
techniques là et sur les faits sur
l'environnement quand vous faites une
variété vous accélérez au fond ça a un
intérêt en particulier je pense en
arboriculture vous avez nous on le
défend dans l'objectif d'avoir des
plantes qui soient plus résistantes ou
dérèglement climatique d'avoir des
plantes qui puissent mieux résister aux
attaques virales diverses et variées et
pourquoi parce que ça permet de réduire
les pesticides mais si on se prive de
tous les moyens donc il faut pas d'eau
faut pas de technique génomique il faut
sortir des pesticides à ce moment là je
sais comment ça finit ça finit je vais
vous le dire ça finit par plus
d'agriculture en France et en Europe et
des produits de l'extérieur qui
viendront avec toutes les techniques on
veut pas donc assumons la part il faut
qu'on ait un rapport on l'a vu
d'ailleurs sur l'affaire du covid il
faut qu'on ait un rapport à la science
qui soit quand même un rapport de
l'aventure de l'humanité le progrès de
l'humanité il est le produit de la de
d'avancer scientifique on marque une
pause et on se retrouve dans un instant
pour parler d'inflation alimentaire et
de revenus des agriculteurs à tout de
suite
[Musique]
du Grand Jury RTL le Figaro LCI Marie
mollet Marc féno et notre invité
aujourd'hui ministre de l'Agriculture et
de la souveraineté alimentaire on parle
maintenant d'inflation alimentaire une
question de Jim jaraz une question sur
les prix de l'alimentation Emmanuel
Macron a appelé hier les les
distributeurs à faire un effort sur leur
marge est-ce que ça veut dire qu'il
profite de la situation et ce qui
profite de l'inflation non mais ça
n'empêche pas qu'il puisse faire un
effort parce qu'on voit bien à quel
point d'abord pendant des années le
monde agricole a fait des efforts on
voit bien à quel point l'industrie
agroalimentaire
a fait des efforts en particulier dans
leur dernière année avec des prix de
l'énergie qui les ont lourdement
impactés et donc la question n'est pas
d'être dans un registre de profiteur ou
pas profiteur mais il faut que chacun
fasse la part et donc la grande
distribution doit faire sa part dans
l'effort et le président de la
République il a rappelé je rappelle
qu'on a essayé aussi au travers des lois
et gallimes de faire en sorte que la
matière première agricole reprenne de la
valeur c'est ce qui s'est passé ces
dernières années mais il faut faire
attention à entre les distributeurs et
les agriculteurs il y a des
transformateurs et les transformateurs
c'est important pour assurer la
souveraineté et donc c'est au
distributeur de faire des choix qui leur
permettent de réduire les marches j'ai
vu les résultats d'un certain nombre
d'entre eux ils sont pas qui est pas de
quoi avoir un peu de moule les
distributeurs eux renvoient la balle
vers les industriels par exemple on a
entendu Michel et Edward Leclerc qui
réclamait à des efforts de la part des
industriels il parlait notamment de
Kellogg's qui a augmenté ses revenus de
17%. moi j'aime bien le sujet alors
c'est un truc typiquement français qui
vise faire en sorte qu'on prend une
marque on dit quelque chose et on essaie
de denier l'ensemble du reste le name
and shame comme on l'appelle ça vous
arrange aussi et vous pouvez pratiquer
personnellement je pense que ça n'a
aucune utilité ceci dit puisque vous me
parlez de Monsieur Leclerc il aura
échappe à personne qu'il a ses propres
responsabilités dans le fait que à force
de dire que le meilleur prix c'est le
prix le plus bas on a dégradé la chaîne
de valeur en terme alimentaire et donc
cette course effrénée au prix le plus
basse c'est une course effrénée à la
perte de souveraineté alimentaire et
donc il y a une responsabilité y compris
d'ailleurs pour Monsieur Leclerc et tous
les autres qui je pense j'imagine et je
leur fais pas grève sont des patriotes
parce que c'est des entreprises
françaises même si ce sont des
indépendants et qu'on leur demande pas
d'être des philanthrope mais ce sont des
entreprises françaises donc ils ont une
responsabilité parce que si un jour je
n'ai plus de chaîne de valeur si un jour
les agriculteurs ne peuvent plus
rémunérer ce qui s'est passé pendant des
années si les industries
agroalimentaires ne peuvent pas se
rémunérer alors il fera quoi Monsieur
Leclerc les autres ils ont cherché à
l'extérieur des frontières leur
alimentation dégradée en termes de
qualité parce qu'elle sera même pas
européenne donc chacun porte sa part de
responsabilité donc je peux entendre que
dans certains cas il y a des relations
qui soient complexes avec des opérateurs
mais il faut aussi entendre que il y a
des marges on voit bien qu'on est au
point culminant de l'inflation on a des
risques un peu là sur le printemps
chacun peut faire sa part d'effort je
rappelle que le gouvernement lui-même a
fait ça par défaut avec le chèque
carburant ce qu'on a fait à l'automne
sur le chèque inflation le fait qu'on
est tenu ce que c'est un tour les
affaires d'inflation on est tenu les
prix sur l'énergie gaz et l'énergie
électrique tout ça fait que des sommes
dans un pays où par les efforts en
particulier de l'État on a l'inflation
la plus facile c'est-à-dire qu'elle ne
touche pas nos concitoyens qui ne la
perçoivent pas différemment mais ne que
chacun fasse sa part dans une phase de
crise on est face à une guerre à nos
portes européennes qui a de longs
impacts et donc chacun doit faire sa
part de l'effort
une question web oui je voulais vous
lire le commentaire de Dominique sur
Facebook qui vous demande un peu un peu
sur le temps de la prova qu'est-ce que
vous connaissez vraiment le prix des
fruits et des légumes parce que pour lui
tout devient trop cher en janvier 2023
les prix d'alimentation ont augmenté en
moyenne de 13 % par an qu'est-ce que
vous lui dites que c'est comme ça il va
falloir s'y habituer non mais le prix
des fruits et légumes c'est vrai mais il
a subi aussi des inflations là on a
décidé de voter une loi sur les
emballages qui a produit donc c'était
plutôt vertueux mais ça produit des
surcos pour ceux qui transformaient donc
oui le prix de oui je connais les prix
des fruits et légumes parce qu'il
m'arrive aussi de vivre comme tout le
monde
après on a besoin d'ailleurs on va
présenter durant le Salon de
l'Agriculture implante souveraineté
fruits et légumes parce qu'on a besoin
au travers des pratiques au travers de
l'évolution vis-à-vis des produits
phytosanitaires au travers de la
compétitivité d'avoir des prix de fruits
et légumes qui sont au travers de
l'accès à l'eau aussi est-ce que vous
dites est-ce que vous dites aux français
il va falloir accepter de payer le prix
si on veut sauver l'agriculture
française mais je pense qu'il faut que
collectivement alors je parle à des
Français qui dont je sais que pour un
certain nombre d'entre eux le sujet du
pouvoir d'achat et le sujet d'un
inflation qu'on dire on n'est pas un
euro c'est pas vrai pour un certain
nombre de Français donc faut faire
attention à ce qu'on dit alors je vais
je vais faire deux réponses à votre oui
si nous ne sommes pas capables de
remettre de la valeur
au sens figuré comme au sens propre à
l'alimentation s'alimenter bien c'est
bon pour sa santé c'est bon tout court
c'est alimenté avec des produits
français c'est assuré notre part de
souveraineté parce que vous voyez bien à
quel point je Poutine depuis 25 ans 20
ans avait construit une stratégie basée
sur deux éléments stratégiques tout le
monde a pensé que c'était complètement
obsolète qui était l'énergie et
l'alimentation l'alimentation c'est une
arme si vous pouvez pas alimenter votre
population
vous êtes en situation de dépendance
mortelle aux autres on voit d'ailleurs
ça et c'est dans cette situation qu'elle
nous vous demandons donc non je dis
juste que à chaque fois qu'on a un acte
de consommateur je suis pas là pour
donner la leçon j'ai jamais fait de ma
vie au français mais l'acte de
consommation il n'est pas anodin il est
une part de notre souveraineté après il
faut qu'on essaie de travailler sur des
dispositifs pour les Français qui n'ont
pas accès aux fruits et légumes parce
que les coups sont trop élevés ou à la
ou la viande parce que les coûts sont
trop élevés les mécanismes qu'on peut
avoir pour soulager pour qui c'est le
plus dur ça vous fait une transition
c'est ça que vous allez marquer non
merci pour cette transition mais on
attend surtout la réponse à cette
question des dispositifs le panier
ont-ils inflation vous n'en avez pas
encore parlé depuis le début de cette
émission c'est un sujet voilà qui court
depuis de très longs mois au sein de
votre gouvernement de votre majorité on
en est alors il y a plusieurs choses
panier anti-inflation c'est plus récent
Olivia Grégoire ma collègue travaille
d'arrache-pied avec Bruno Le Maire pour
essayer de trouver avec les
distributeurs mais ça rejoint ce qu'a le
président de la République hier que vous
avez évoqué c'est le panier
anti-inflation ça doit être un outil ou
c'est la distribution qui prend sa
charge tu sais pour venir sur les
agriculteurs ou sur la transformation là
ça sert à des prix bloquer sur un
certain nombre de produits d'essayer de
regarder ce qu'on peut faire pour
garantir pendant une période donnée aux
Français donc on est en train de
n'avance pas parce que Bruno
oui ils ont fait ils ont fait une
interview commune dans la semaine où ils
ont redis ce que devrait être les bases
pourquoi c'est compliqué il y a un
deuxième sujet qui est le chèque
alimentaire donc c'est ça qu'on
travaille depuis plusieurs mois parce
que c'est quelle nature de produits
c'est dans un panier
quels sont les produits qu'on met c'est
plutôt des végétaux c'est plutôt des
produits donc il y a un débat avec tout
le monde parce que en quoi le panier dès
lors que vous donnez un nombre de
produits vous avez besoin de déterminer
ce nombre et et les les distributeurs ne
disent pas tous la même chose
deuxièmement il faut qu'on se garantisse
du fait qu'il y aura pas d'effet de bord
c'est à dire que ça vienne taper la
transformation les agriculteurs donc
c'est tout ça qu'on est en train de
travailler honnêtement ça fait un mois
qu'on essaie d'y travailler c'est après
on a chaque alimentaire
pour le panier là
l'idée c'est dans la quinzaine de jours
d'avoir un d'essayer de voir le
dispositif qu'on peut proposer mais il
faut le faire en responsabilité
vis-à-vis des distributeurs enfin c'est
eux qui doivent être en responsabilité
d'ailleurs et de l'objectif n'est pas de
détricoter ce que nous avons battre
patiemment bâti depuis 3-4 ans
c'est-à-dire de remettre de la chaîne de
valeur de la valeur dans la chaîne
alimentaire si c'est pour détruire ça je
vois bien ceux qui veulent s'en saisir
on remet tout en couple propose
justement un chèque alimentaire consacré
aux fruits et légumes peut-être 100
euros pour les personnes les plus
précaires est-ce que vous êtes prêts à
dire on est en train de travailler dans
la dans le dans le plan de souveraineté
frisé alors les effets national ne dis
pas que fruits et légumes plus
compliqués que ça parce que quel lieu de
distribution quel type de produit
transformé ou pas transformé fruits et
légumes uniquement ou d'autres donc on a
on a quand même tout ça sous l'apparence
de la facilité du sujet c'est un peu
plus complexe que ça deux on n'a pas
envie de stigmatiser les gens c'est à
dire ça touchera plutôt les Français ça
c'est un peu tous les Français qui sont
les plus en difficulté faut pas que ce
soit stigmatisant troisièmement on a des
banques alimentaires qui sont très
précieuses dans les territoires donc il
faut pas oublier le rôle Émile est-ce
qu'on se est-ce que ça peut être un
vecteur de l'amélioration de
l'alimentation le sujet principal c'est
qu'il y a un certain nombre de gens vous
l'avez dit d'ailleurs même si c'était
sous la forme de boutade de votre
interlocuteur il y a un certain nombre
de gens qui ne mangent pas tous les
légumes vous avez un tiers des gens en
France seulement qui sont dans le la
tendance qui est demandé par le
programme nutrition santé c'est à dire 5
fruits et légumes par jour un tiers
seulement y accède donc ça c'est de la
précarité et ça derrière c'est des
effets de santé quand on sait que ces
documenter d'un point de vue
scientifique que manger cinq fruits et
légumes par jour c'est mieux pour la
santé donc ça c'est ça qu'il faut
essayer de travailler mais c'est voyez
c'est un processus fin qu'il faut faire
une question sur le marché du bio qui
est d'ailleurs peut-être connexe à celle
du pouvoir d'achat après plusieurs
années fasses et une croissance à deux
chiffres le marché du bio est en crise
et baisse pour la deuxième année
consécutive ce qui a un problème du côté
des consommateurs qui privilégie
privilégie désormais le prix par rapport
aux conditions de production d'un
produit d'un aliment d'abord par nature
se méfier des années fast quand vous
avez une croissance de points un moment
ça s'arrête que les armes ne montent pas
jusqu'au ciel et sans doute n'avaient
pas été vu qu'à un moment le marché
allait se stabiliser ce qu'on voit
d'ailleurs en France c'est valable j'en
parlais avec mes collègues espagnols et
allemand on le voit dans les autres pays
Européens on est dans une phase de
stabilisation donc à ceux qui nous
expliquaient qu'il fallait faire tout en
bio il faut être un peu on avait raison
de dire essayons d'avancer
progressivement qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé dans cette période inflationniste
c'est pour des raisons de budget les
Français ont descendu en gamme si je
peux dire en tout cas descendu en prix
et puis deuxième élément qu'on a sans
doute moins vu sur lequel je souhaite
qu'on travaille d'ailleurs on a annoncé
qu'on mettrait des moyens
complémentaires en termes de
communication c'est que la vérité la
décroissance arrive avant le vrai pic
d'inflation elle arrive après la covid
après la crise covid pourquoi parce que
les Français et nous les avons tous
poussé plutôt redécouvert le les
produits locaux et donc le localisme est
venu un peu se substituer d'une certaine
façon dans les choix alimentaires aux
Français donc on a besoin avec la
filière bio faut reconnaître qu'ils sont
très en crise pour faut pas nier
l'actrice qu'il traverse avec des gens
qui ont fait des choix qui sont parfois
des choix de changement de modèle qui
sont très compliqués dans l'état est-ce
que l'État les soutiens suffisamment
aujourd'hui on est en train de préparer
un plan pour à la fois les soutenir dans
la conjoncture enfin l'État n'est pas là
pour soutenir la demande l'État est là
pour faire en sorte que la démante soit
plus forte de quelle manière on peut les
aider c'est conjoncturellement sur
certaines filières on est en train de
regarder deuxième élément qu'est-ce
qu'on fait comme action de communication
mais faut qu'elle soit manifestement
plus efficace ou qu'elle vienne cibler
mieux que ce qu'on avait fait jusqu'à
lors parce que si c'est pour faire les
mêmes manifestement on a un problème
troisième élément on peut au travers de
ce qu'on a fait dans la loi egaline
dites égaline 1
soutenir les collectivités accompagner
les collectivités dans l'intégration de
produits soucis sous label de qualité
sous produits bio on avait prévu 20% et
50% produit de qualité au globale dans
la restauration au domicile en
particulier la restauration scolaire et
là il faut qu'on accompagne mieux sans
doute et que on est qu'à 6 7%. donc on a
besoin d'aller plus loin sur ce sujet là
donc la commande publique la
communication la gestion de crise c'est
surtout c'est se lever là qu'on va
essayer de jouer
en janvier vous avez annoncé marcéno la
fin des dérogations sur les
néonicotinoïdes pour la betterave après
une décision de la Cour de justice
européenne n'annonce a provoquer la
colère des agriculteurs et des
manifestations ont eu à Paris à
Clermont-Ferrand ou à Saint-Étienne le
poids des normes notamment
environnemental est-il entre un Marc
veino de tuer l'agriculture française et
c'est le risque qu'il faut conjurer mais
reconnaissons oui mais oui vous dites
oui c'est énorme tu mets notre agressive
nous avons des normes alors d'abord vous
ne trouverez pas sur le chemin de la
démagogique démagogie qui disent qu'il
faut pas de norme parce que c'est très
facile derrière un micro derrière une
tribune pour être populaire en tout cas
un temps de dire on se fiche des sujets
environnementaux se fiche de sujets de
chanter quand vous discutez derrière les
agriculteurs ils ont tout à fait
conscience il y a un certain nombre de
choses il est mieux qu'on soit sorti
donc c'est pas le sujet uniquement
deuxième élément qu'est-ce qui fait que
les agriculteurs comprennent pas c'est
que on peut comprendre non seulement
leur exaspération mais parfois leur
colère il y a comme une offense qui leur
est faite on leur dit il y a qu'à
interdire comme si l'interdiction allait
produire la solution l'interdiction ça
produit pas la solution mais quand en
plus l'interdiction elle est que
nationale et que dans vos frontières que
vous vous croisez vos collègues et vos
voisins allemands espagnols italiens qui
vous disent c'est bizarre chez nous la
molécule est autorisée alors là là vous
prenez un risque mortel pour
l'agriculture donc on a travaillé
d'abord sur ces sujets là au niveau
européen c'est si c'est mauvais ou si
c'est bon c'est au niveau européen que
ça se décide s'il y a des risques c'est
plutôt niveau repeint que ça décide ça
n'empêche pas que nous travaillons avec
nos agences nos propres agences
nationales mais on a besoin d'eux on a
besoin de coordonner un calendrier je
peux pas avoir une décision qui
s'applique sous six mois et ne pas
souhaité laisser le temps de la solution
c'est comme si on disait à l'industrie
automobile vous savez pas vous allez
passer l'électrique en 6 mois c'est
impossible de faire ça les normes
françaises effectivement en termes
phytosanitaires sont plus sévères qu'en
Europe 450 substances favoriser dans
lieu contre seulement 300 en France
est-ce que vous pouvez assez volontiers
parce que ces 450 dans l'ensemble de
l'Europe et il y a des endroits on n'a
pas besoin de ces molécules vous
m'accorderez
autorise des substances qui ont été
interdites en France qui sont autorisés
chez nos voisins pour justement éviter
que y ait moi le chat sur lequel je me
mets c'est d'abord il y a des juridiques
je rappelle que nous avons ces passe
gouvernement c'est pas le précédent
c'est il y a le principe de précaution
le principe de non régressions et des
lois qui ont interdit des molécules pour
certaines en particulier les
néonicotinoïdes je veux bien qu'on
réinterroge tous les sujets mais on a un
sujet d'urgence c'est comment j'assure
au betteravier pour le sujet qui nous
préoccupe une forme de sécurité sur
l'année qui se passe 2 il faut qu'on
travaille sur les alternatives après je
pense que le c'est ce qui a lancé le
président de la République ce que j'ai
fait il y a 15 jours j'ai dit il faut
qu'on arrête d'avoir du travail en silo
l'ancêtre dit des choses des instituts
techniques dit des choses l'INRA et dit
des choses des filières disent des
choses essayons de mieux coordonner ça
se fait déjà mais essayons de mieux pas
encore donné nos travaux pour que
l'interdiction de la molécule ne
viennent pas sur heurté à une absence de
solution parce que sinon ça on va dans
le cas donc c'est plutôt comme ça qu'il
faut essayer de travailler
alimentaire qui
dépose les décrire les interdictions
est-ce que vous dites il faut retirer
son pouvoir d'interdiction à l'ancêtre
ce que demande la FNSEA essayons tout ça
c'est des débats qui sont des débats
sans fin ça c'est pardon je peux
exprimer le sentiment qu'il faut d'abord
qu'on essaie de travailler mieux
ensemble parce que si c'est pas l'agence
de sécurité sanitaire française ça sera
le repère donc n'éludons pas les
questions ce que je veux c'est qu'on
coordonne
les programmes de forme de recherche le
programme d'innovation avec les
inquiétudes qu'on entend sur certaines
molécules le problème c'est qu'on
n'arrive pas à les coordonnées c'est ça
la difficulté une question sur les
réseaux sociaux oui il y a deux visions
qui s'affrontent chez nos internautes
qui vous écoutent depuis le début de
cette émission il y a un internaute qui
dit en fait vous allez voir en fait le
vrai ministre de l'Agriculture c'est la
FNSEA et un autre internaute Grégory qui
lui pensait bien que tout ça ne se joue
pas en France mais ce joue en Europe
donc un coup fnseur un coup c'est à
cause de l'Union européenne et la France
en fait dans tout ça c'est nous sommes
partis intégrant de l'Union européenne
donc on se bat régulièrement ça prend
trop de place et que ça se fait au
détriment des agriculteurs européennes
que ça se fait au détriment des
agriculteurs non non parce que c'est si
on a encore une agriculture puissante
c'est grâce à l'Union européenne c'est
parce qu'on a eu une politique agricole
commune donc on ne commençons pas non
plus à venir si nous n'avions pas
l'Union européenne nous serions livrés à
la concurrence alors total à l'extérieur
de nos frontières et à l'intérieur de
l'Union européenne c'est moi
l'harmonisation dès lors qu'elle est
européenne elle ne me pose pas de
problème elle ne me pose problème quand
elle est que française et donc sans
doute c'est le point d'équilibre qu'il
faut essayer de trouver c'est-à-dire
faut qu'on essaie d'expliquer que c'est
au niveau européen que se pose ces
sujets mais que c'est pas parce que
c'est au niveau européen que j'irai
aller raconter parce que je sais que je
leur mens en prononçant cette phrase
vous agriculteurs il y a pas une
transition opérée ça veut pas dire
d'ailleurs qu'on a pas besoin de produit
phytosanitaire ce qu'il dit il y a plus
de produits phytosanitaires en 5 ans
c'est comme s'il disait on passe à la
voiture électrique en 6 mois il y a des
produits phytosanitaires d'ailleurs tout
est chimie tout ce qu'il y a dans le
studio est chimie et nous sommes
nous-mêmes à porter des vêtements qui
sont produits de la chimie donc ne
faisons pas non plus un grief
particulier à ce secteur simplement on a
besoin quand il y a des alertes des
sujets sanitaires des sujets
environnementaux de se poser la question
des alternatives je suis posé la
question on a dit tout à l'heure sur les
nouvelles techniques génomiques de se
poser la question des biocontrôles donc
j'ai besoin de resynchroniser ça et donc
la volonté qu'on a et que je porte au
niveau européen c'est d'avoir des alliés
on a accéléré sur les techniques
génomiques parce qu'on s'est mis à
plusieurs ministres européens pour
demander à la Commission d'avoir un
papier
avant la fin du cycle électoral qui
débute en 2024 pour l'Union européenne
elle est un peu d'actualité avec la
réforme des retraites Marc phéno vous
êtes aussi président du MoDem la réforme
des retraites arrive au Sénat la semaine
prochaine mardi en commission une
question de Jim Jared une citation
plutôt de quelqu'un que vous connaissez
très bien qui a dit une partie très
importante de l'opinion ne se reconnaît
pas dans cette réforme est-ce que vous
savez de qui s'agit non il s'agit de
François Bayrou le patron du MoDem
partie auquel vous appartenait
peut-être est-ce que vous partagez le
constat du président de votre partie
j'en parle beaucoup avec François
bayraud
la question c'est qu'on arrive à dire
mieux sans doute parce que c'est quand
même ça le sujet ce pourquoi nous
faisons cette réforme faisons cette
réforme parce que nous voulons d'abord
sauver le système par répartition et que
le plus injuste serait que le système
des répartition disparaissent parce que
se créerait un système par
capitalisation vous avez pas besoin
d'aller d'aller de l'autre côté de
l'Atlantique vous voyez des gens qui ont
70 ou 75 ans et qui parce qu'ils n'ont
pas de retraite sont obligés de
travailler donc le système pareil
partition faut le sauver c'est une
question de justice à l'intérieur du
système ce que nous avons c'est
aujourd'hui il y a plein d'injustices
donc on essaye à l'intérieur de ce de
cet effort qui est demandé parce que
deux ans de plus personne ne vient dire
ou gouvernement dans la majorité il y a
ici des parlementaires ce n'est pas un
effort qui est demandé aux Français mais
on a besoin sans doute de mieux
expliciter ce en quoi on sauve le
système par répartition et ça vient
protéger les plus modestes d'entre nous
deux on demande un effort à tout le
monde et 3 à l'intérieur de cela
qu'est-ce qu'on essaye de mettre comme
mesure de justice le travail le débat a
commencé à l'Assemblée nationale il va
se poursuivre au Sénat président de la
République hier dans les contacts qu'il
avait avec les Français aussi explicité
que il y avait sans doute le sujet
autour des femmes et puis le sujet aussi
autour de les familles sur lesquelles il
fallait cheval de bataille notamment du
MoDem la question des femmes il l'avait
fait des propositions sur le sujet qui
n'ont pas été retenus est-ce que
finalement le gouvernement écoute plus
par exemple les républicains que le
modem non alors moi je vais vous dire
j'ai été président de groupe et j'en
parle souvent avec Jean-Paul Mathilde la
question c'est pas de porter
l'amendement comme un comme un drapeau
et de dire c'est le mien c'est pas le
tien genre je constate que sur un
certain nombre de sujets nous étions
plutôt sur 64 que sur 65 quand même pas
tout à fait le même sujet vous voyez on
a plutôt été suivi on était plutôt sur
un certain nombre d'améliorations qui
ont été proposés dans le débat à
l'Assemblée nationale donc chacun prend
sa part après tout que des gens chez les
républicains j'aimerais d'ailleurs que
du côté gauche nous ayons aussi des gens
avec lesquels nous puissions discuter et
c'est de trouver parce que c'est
d'intérêt général cette affaire là
est-ce qu'on fait là c'est pour tous les
gouvernements qui succéderont donc si on
pouvait trouver des voies d'équilibre
c'est n'est pas une affaire que de la
majorité contre le reste du monde donc
on a besoin de travailler avec tout le
monde Marc fais-nous à mesure que le
débat parlementaire se fait sur ce sujet
de la réforme des retraites il y a des
aménagements au texte qui coûtent cher
finalement pour trouver des économies
supplémentaires est-ce que vous seriez
favorable par exemple à accélérer la fin
des régimes spéciaux le ministre du
Travail Olivier du stop dit que c'est
une possibilité d'aller chez nos
confrères de BFM TV c'est ce que je
souhaite faire la droite qui est
majoritaire
je vais pas être très sympa mais c'est
ce que je souhaite faire la droite
depuis 25 ans est-ce qu'elle annonce
depuis 35 et qu'elle n'a pas fait depuis
25 ans simplement c'est nous qui le
faisons et je pense que c'est une mesure
de pour les Français donc accélérer la
non attendez
l'alignement des régimes spéciaux c'est
une mesure de justice deuxième élément
que ça fasse partie enfin on est dans un
pic est bizarre en fait on peut pas
avoir de débat vous voyez non mais avec
vous aussi on peut pas dire examinons la
question sans avoir un avis définitif et
donc dans le débat parlementaire qu'on
puisse regarder si ça peut être une des
voix que c'est une question examinée
sans avoir d'avis c'est les gens qui
pensent en noir ou blanc ils ont
beaucoup de chance dans la vie mais je
pense qu'ils se trompent je pense que
c'est les nuances de gris sont pas
mauvaises et donc il me semble que qu'on
puisse poser ça aussi comme un des
éléments n'est pas une mauvaise idée
question sur les réseaux sociaux oui là
je m'adresse plus à l'ancien ministre
des Relations avec le Parlement vous
avez été pendant tout le débat sur les
retraites on a reçu énormément de
questions d'internautes qui s'interroge
sur la retraite des sénateurs et il y a
même un député qui estime qu'il faut
revenir sur ce régime spécial et tout
simplement l'annuler vous qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez
comment dire on est quand même un pays
qui adore se chercher des boucs
émissaires
les sénateurs sont des bouquets mystères
ils ont un système d'ailleurs je le
rappelle ils ont un système qui est
équilibré et un système qui est
équilibré parce qu'il serait sûr que bon
ils ont manifestement bien géré leur
caisse de retraite bon que chacun
s'aligne d'ailleurs le président du
Sénat que je connais bien il a dit on
fera le pas nécessaire mais cette espèce
de si toi tu l'as pas fait cette espèce
de on tire vers le bas en permanence les
autres en disant et en montrant du doigt
comme je le fais là tel ou telle
catégorie vous m'entendez pas dire sur
la régime des retraites régies spéciaux
tel ou telle catégorie je dis juste une
question d'alignement le président du
Sénat a dit que il verrait aussi à ce
que le Sénat fasse sa part mais
attention à ce genre d'exercice en
particulier pour avoir été ministre des
relations avec des parlements je trouve
que personne ne gagne d'une chambre à
l'autre à taper d'une chambre sur
l'autre ça n'est pas bon pour la
démocratie on a besoin du Sénat et on a
besoin de l'Assemblée nationale ça fait
partie de l'équipe on est bien content
là aussi de trouver le Sénat en ce
moment pour essayer d'avoir des débats
que parfois les députés qui sont ici
présents regrette de ne pas avoir eu
marques vous venez d'un territoire rural
c'était Loir-et-Cher vous avez été maire
du village de marchenoire pendant près
de 10 ans lors des législatives un grand
nombre de territoires ruraux ont basculé
aurasemblement national comment vous
l'expliquer
dispositif à travers ce qu'on a fait au
travers de France relance un certain
nombre de jours il y a un sentiment de
relégation dans les territoires ruraux
quand vous avez vu successivement ce que
j'ai vu après moi j'essaie de
reconstruire comme elu local disparaître
le bas la boulangerie la poste et on
vous a expliqué comment
vous faites pour empêcher la progression
c'est un je pense que c'est du temps
long et c'est un élément de reconquête
c'est un élément de retraite oui pour
essayer de mettre à la fois de pas
cultiver le c'était mieux avant et en
même temps de dire ça sera bien demain
quand même vous voyez c'est ça qu'il
faut qu'on essaie de faire c'est c'est
les territoires qui ont le sentiment
qu'ils ont plus d'Amiens la
réindustrialisation c'est un chemin la
la réappropriation des services publics
c'est un chemin le le respect des
traditions c'est un chemin il faut
laisser les gens vive leur tradition dès
lors qu'elles ne viennent pas nuire aux
autres alors moi ça m'arrive de pas être
d'accord avec des traditions enfin je
les laisse et y compris tes nouvelles
traditions qui se construisent une toute
dernière question exception ça nous
amène finalement à la question de 2027
et au spectre d'une éventuelle victoire
de Marine Le Pen est-ce que le bloc
central peut survivre à l'après Emmanuel
Macron comment faire pour que ce bloc
qui a été constitué pendant deux
quinquennat n'explose pas d'abord je
peux pas dire que je parle à mon aise
mais le blog central nous l'avons fait
vivre autour de François Bayrou en
particulier depuis un certain nombre
d'années pour ne pas dire de décennies
le brosse le bloc central il existe
c'est la solution pour donc
François Bayrou dira ce qu'il a à dire
le jour venu mais vous souhaitez mais en
tout cas il a une place éminente mais il
a dit lui-même que c'est pas le sujet du
moment je trouve qu'il y a une forme
d'indécence avec tous les sujets qu'on a
devant nous on a évoqué les sujets
climatiques les sujets les souverainetés
etc de commencer à parler c'est la
dernière question de l'émission
mais je dis juste
cet espace central je ne le sens pas
menacé tout simplement parce que dans
l'opinion ça existe et comme ça existe
il trouvera son incarnation et trouvera
son chemin merci beaucoup Marc fenault
merci beaucoup d'avoir